now the final tool I want to show you
today is going to help you track down a
lot of your compute performance problems
so this is actually the profile tabs on
chrome devtools clicking this option
will give you three options or more
depending on what chrome decides to roll
out in the future the first one you need
to take a look at is collect javascript
CPU profile by hitting the start button
what actually occurs is chrome is
recording all of the application and
JavaScript code that's running right now
hitting stop actually gives us this
beautiful chart that allows us to see
where my JavaScript was going now this
is actually broken up into two areas on
the top here you can actually see a
generalization of spike of CPU time
utilized and on the bottom these
beautiful beautiful colored line is
actually what we call a flame chart
scrolling my mouse cursor actually
allows me to zoom in and what you see is
a treasure trove of information this
flame chart doesn't just show us pretty
rainbow pictures on the screen but it
actually represents an inverse call
graph whose horizontal size represents
how long a function took to execute so
for example you can see that the animate
function was called here and then it
called the run function then the draw
function then another draw then another
draw and eventually we keep going up and
up and up the chain of course hovering
over shows you the total time that these
events took and then we're in the name
shows you who actually called that
function now you can see we have pillars
of function calls basically that's the
call graph going through but between
them we have this really interesting
little program bar that no one seems to
understand what's going on there what
you're looking at here is that these
tall pillars actually represent a frame
of computation so this is actually
requestanimationframe where the page is
updated scripts are run everything's
drawn to your screen and then when it's
done it relinquishes control back over
to chrome what you see here in the
program bar accounts for the time that
the browser takes before it comes back
and gives control to the game again so
you can see here that we're actually
giving about 12 milliseconds for chrome
to do its job and then once we get back
it takes about 2 milliseconds for us to
update the scene do any important
calculations and move on to the next
frame